oh my
God show the audience I think 911
happened though what were you say oh my
God just tell us about the origies when
you peel back my foreskin my head is
pretty pink wait okay touch me right
now we're Ultra Al alpha or we're Ultra
beta I don't know the difference but I'm
okay cuz I like to
[Music]
win and welcome back everybody to a very
special flaming episode of the careful
boys where today we have the ultimate
flamer Mr Jason chenny in the room I see
a flamer what is Flaming what is Flaming
me cuz this is a very very special he's
a flaming hot do you know what that
means this this is the off the Record
topic he's super hot yeah super hot
right super flaming okay you're
extremely flaming is that good
absolutely I'm flaming yeah I don't
believe you man we like flaming hot this
is this is what all the fans want to
know whether they said it or not whether
they said and you're you're the main
guest here okay so if all of us yourself
included you're probably the most we're
gay we're gay right wait why you say if
all of us were gay okay
hey sounds gay I'm in we know this okay
you have to rank us and give us some
reasons why you would date Us in what
order oh I like this you so you have to
I have to date all out of all of us but
you have to rank us which one would you
want to date the most dude this is so
gay yeah this sounds gay he's in who
would you want to date and then who
would you not want to date and then
who's mid yeah and why who's in the
afterthought what are you attracted to
Quality personality the most and then
the least dude my answer is going to be
so specific and
juicy that's what we want that's what we
want bro where do I start juice you want
you start start the lowest theow yeah
the least there's no lowest can I just
say no when you say the lowest and once
you name that person they have to go
outside of the office it's like a dating
show they're eliminated and at the end
you're oneon-one with the person that
you want the most this is a bachelor The
Bachelor The
Bachelor you have to tell them straight
in the eyes all the characteristics as
why you want them the most you two get a
free workout session at barbell Brigade
or lard Jitsu or you could
do no you I take it back I take it back
I withdraw my invitation hey come on
final round you have to hold hands with
that and look into their eyes that's so
weird we do it like or we do it like
uh dude that's [__] up man save your
top picks first like like you know like
the bachelor I like I like the low one
gets kicked out the office let's do that
all right you have to go hang out with
can for the rest of the video they got
to go get they got to go 7-Eleven get us
it's not elimination it's just one guy
yeah yeah what first guy who's okay so
who do you eliminate least least and
those say their name for describe them
yeah yeah describe them first before you
say the name before you do a reveal and
why you don't like
them okay Anthony please excuse
yourself just
joking just joking never tell me to my
face dude you're [__] buff
man an think he's in a big shirt but a
lot of musle dude seriously dude I'm not
gay but I don't want to R lose right now
I'm just like competitive I don't want
to be the first guy want to be the guy
am I really getting kicked out no I just
said a random somebody has somebody has
to go oh my God somebody has to be
eliminated so crazy who's the least guy
that you would get dude this is going to
hurt my heart what do you mean keep it
real bro just be real just say it I will
I will don't point of me like that dude
wrong okay hold up hold up I could make
you feel like you're with the woman bro
you can't be selling yourself yeah you
can't sell yourself oh why wait maybe we
should get a chance to sell ourselves
cuz it might change his mind I just want
to hear what he has to say just go get
her over with Mar get so frustrated he's
too anxious he's too anxious he's like
just say it just [__] I can't take the
anticipation come on yeah which which
one of us is the least desirable to you
and bro this is so stressful man you
have to say why just sit right there no
one's feelings are going to be hurt of
course it is no it's not it is it is
going to be hurt hell yeah dude no one
none of us want to lose if you get
eliminated you sit on the couch in the
background sit back there all right sit
back there all right hurry up dude what
don't this what this is like getting
married you can't say hurry up describe
them and why you don't want to date them
and then pick and say about wait wait
and give them a chance to change your
mind okay well can I can I say some
stuff give them a chance to change your
mind all right go okay but everybody has
to say what their best and worst quality
is you know you know why I don't want to
do that why the reason why I don't want
to do that is because I actually want to
hear from you what you think of us okay
and also if we tell you what we say
you're going to use our words and you're
not play I don't know what you yeah but
that was a strategy bro and also you
just [__] my strategy barly cuz if you
imagine how he really is going to [__]
you this was trying to wiggle it out
wiggle out of it okay I think I know
your [__] games you [__]
[__] he has to pass judgment first and
then we have to defend okay okay yeah
that
work all right oh my
God show The Audience Show The Audience
Show me the proof oh my
God
yeah bro you look so cool you look so
[__]
cool show me the proof that's how he got
out of it dude he show shut the [__] up
that's how he
got that was a secret weapon what the
flying
[__] you look really cool in this you
look hella cool dude you look really Co
he like an action hero don't play on
this bit you don't you're not a part of
this B I know but what is this somebody
explain but I know it was a weapon and I
have used it
that's the last one you could use is
this you [__] greatest
episode is this you back no no it's not
it's not it's not don't tell me there's
more than one it's it's for you and
Dina please guys Anthony won't let us
sell these shirts please beg him for me
he won't listen to me we want to sell
these shirts too far it's not a merch
it's not a merch it it's not a merch
item it's too far people's lives got
hurt it's not a merch item it's just a
oneoff for it sounds like a two off to
me or is it a six off is I had to get a
minimum of
two I didn't want to can you imagine
being the guy having to print this [__]
out and he's just like what the [__] who
the [__] is Anthony Lee oh man show me
the it's not to go anywhere but here I'm
wear this to the quest Halloween party
show me the
proof I'm upset with you for
participating I didn't even know I'm
that shirt he didn't even know what he
put on shirt though this is a really
good this really well made [__]
eliminate
somebody you're being really angry right
yeah eliminate me best we're going to
get a streamy for this don't Nick just m
oh oh my God you shouldn't have gave it
to him dude he's going to wear it the
whole day show me
proof cuz uh you [__] I think
this shirt I like this one better than
the careful Boy shirt dude hey hey whoa
whoa who I'm just joking I'm just joking
so like who's the first one you want to
all right you got pick somebody you got
to pick somebody it's okay Anthony Lee
has a really good dance about how let
him say his
[__] how 911 isn't real oh you oh is
that what this is no it's not is that
what this is cuz it has a building
everything guys people got
hurt wait remember we talked about
earlier back to the dating game this the
worst dating game ever shirt anymore
what who who and where and I shirtm who
where and how yeah um you don't have to
keep wearing it but okay you know what
maybe but I don't know I don't mind it
it's a good shirt though stop focusing
on a
shirt it's a good
shirt um the other one would have been a
better when we talked about 911 let me
ask you something I know that was [__]
up if I did I think because but who is
the least
emotionally uh I have to know who's
emotionally less available that's up to
you to decide who do you think out of
all you figure yeah you judge us we why
don't you start asking us questions like
a dating show and maybe we can answer
you Jud specific you just eliminate us
all right how do you guys show your love
language what's your first and second
how do you show it not how you want to
receive it but how do you show it go
touch huh physical touch physical touch
is what's the second one I'm just
curious [__] just tell me the second so
touch is the first one um probably
quality time oh hey okay hey J Jenny I'm
the exact same baby touch and quality
time quality time okay what about qual
quality time act acts of service and
quality time acts of service what's
yours but first and second how do you
like to show it how I show it is acts of
service and quality time wow okay now
it's down to you touch guys [__] because
touch guys is like that's an easy thing
like everybody could touch not to touch
well not to touch your heart okay touch
me right
now is that your question
no wa I'm technically the only one
touching your
your okay touch but what uh touch and
then quality time and your is touch and
quality time too yeah um I like to
cuddle dude okay so he's obviously
eliminating one of us yeah it's one of
you guys probably going to be me cuz I
don't have a cool shirt with my face on
it dude can we stop bringing attention
to it that's my job okay I can do it cuz
it's relevant to me comedy poor timing
poor execution okay okay cool all right
yeah I think 9911 happened though what
were you saying oh my
God wait did you say it didn't happen oh
my god oh I don't know because you said
no okay continue okay can you see
yourself dating a 9/11 denier though oh
no see never he's not really into
conspiracy theorists so it's down to
Nick or Anthony and first round El first
round in hey dude do you like my ears do
you think they're
hot um that's enough no no I could I
could grow no I know a no when I see one
no I could grow to like them I don't
like that oh like if you if the quality
time is good what what do you like do
for quality time who do you have more
chemistry with me or Nick um you guys
are both nice guys I like that um the
comments usually say you have better
chemistry than Anthony though people
think I hate you no but you have a good
heart you don't know that I would
emphasize the tea okay how how how how
big is your
Venus yeah inches it's relative to his
height it's kind of cold in here no on
SW we're talking on swole okay let me
ask you something are you a size queen
Jason chenny what what's your penis
color oh mine's dark it's really dark
yeah my ball sack is a little darker
than the shaft and there's like a total
of maybe like three shades of a nice
tanned Brown okay when you peel back my
hores skin my head is pretty pink wait
don't insert yourself into our situation
Joe I can't compete with pig penis like
s's G I'm
in Joe just locked in dude yeah he's not
even one of the options you're just
giving some stuff some details throw in
a bone okay but what um we're running
out of time man we still got everybody
sitting at the table eliminate one okay
when you kiss in the mouth do you guys
what is it like describe your kiss okay
I'll say this I think this is a little
weird but um recently I've been wearing
a lot of nose strips and I need them to
be able to breathe through my nose so I
don't mouth breathe yeah so I do that
and then also um I like to open my eyes
and make eye contact while I kiss yeah
me
too wait wa what do you mean I [__] I
thought you didn't want to be eliminated
no you like to look while you kiss yeah
because it's like I like to enjoy what
it is in front of me but two people
can't do it you can't see that [__]
though no you could are you eye to eye
no you see a little bit like you're not
like [__] you know what I mean you're
like a little bit like yeah
yeah like that you just see a little bit
of something do you close your eyes the
whole time uh if it feels really good I
close my eyes yeah okay are you
aggressive with your lips uh when I was
younger I would be a little bit more
aggressive now I'm very very
sensual damn sensual slow is that is
that what you like I like sensual slow
he said
damn cuz it sucks that I have to let man
that sucks that I have to make the
decision for you but I guess I all right
you have to make a decision do a
countdown from six y'all all right 6 5 4
just point to who you're eliminating 2 1
go man Ryan's got to
go you weren't even the option what a
curveball no is it is it it had to do a
twist I don't know what that I just all
right I'm out who's next who's next I
don't know
man
Jing it's elimination but what if I want
to Ryan you Fu okay my bad [__] up
game over dude all right round two round
two here we go you got now you got to
describe something that you're attracted
to and then who you believe does not
have this quality at all
yeah okay okay I got it I got it okay
who's um big toe is the
thickest dude you can't have a big the
biggest my big toe is kind of thick
that's pretty thick big toe that's
thicker than mine big toe yeah my big
toe's kind of thi I bet an got long big
toe not that
noral do you have a feet footage no I
don't have a fe fo
footage my big to's like a [__] I got
pretty that's a thick big look can I
tell you something B you have a really
nice personality and are you're really
organized how do you know I'm organized
huh you see my
backpack but because of your big toe I
would have to you go oh that's messed up
just because of this guy sucks on toes I
didn't know you were superficial like
that he's a feet footish dude how did it
start with you almost eliminating these
guys and now you eliminate part of they
weren't even in the [__] danger zone
TV they were it's a switch the producers
are crazy on the show T now we're down
to almost the final round all Ryan
what's the last category of all right we
are at uh round two round two you know
what I I didn't think I was going to
make it this far so I want to thank
everyone at home and my family for
helping me get make it this far so I
thought I was going to be eliminated
before we even started the show I'm just
happy to be here I think your long hair
is keeping you in dude I know okay I
tried what um who when you get angry
what how do you deal with like
arguments um like how do you deal with
like tension and how do you deal with
like you know when when we're a couple
how do we I'll probably like Gaslight
you and blame you for my problems he's
trying to get eliminated don't listen to
that yeah why do you guys say that man I
want to
stay I'm trying to win bro why why would
you say gas light me man I'm trying to
stay I'm present body
why why why why
we okay my dad's got diabetes IES
diabetes all right my dad got to Gold to
well I'm just answering your question
yeah you gas you gas me that's your
thing I mean it's not my thing but like
I I maybe it's my problem okay that's
your problem so you're a gaslighter on
AC
me I'll say I'll I'll yell and I go I'm
sorry I lost control oh man like that's
really nice and I said I said I love you
I like that man after after gas you
oh true true my dick a hard no um it is
true wrong yeah because you do you
actually apologize after how long after
you Gaslight somebody you apologize I
apologize before the other person can
realize that I did wrong wrong
um no fall back on that one too strong
wrong I I I think I'm pretty calm In the
Heat of an argument really you're pretty
calm I'm pretty calm but is this a scary
C or you're like you kind you really
sell it until you kind of normal what do
you mean sell it I try to be calm I try
to be calm as best I can but then
sometimes I stay a little quiet quiet
until I you know and then what are the
intrusive thoughts what are the
intrusive thoughts that when you're
quiet is there choking involved no no
choking no choking no nothing physical
damn damn that's a down SP off no yeah
like I choke all the time dude I [__]
choke people oh no no okay no I um I
tried to be fair I to be fair I try not
to raise my voice and I try to find a
solution I think wow these guys are
lying to you dude that's a good one I
try to do that I don't mean it doesn't
mean I do it he's he's in a stable
relationship I know that is really nice
but you both of you guys too though yeah
I think he's maybe he's trying to
divulge some sort of secret to his
relationship no but he seems pretty
upend you seem like a sneaky guy his
shirt say sounds gay I mean you seem
like a sneaky guy dude I'm just joking
we all know you like just tell us about
the ories can I say something can I say
something the chemistry between you guys
is [__] through the roof look at his
deflecting skills yeah why are you
deflecting man is that deflecting or is
that just this is like reverse
psychology he's trying to make us look
good so he can win somehow and that's
that's 4 3 2 1 who's cut okay you got to
[Music]
go sorry sorry by bye-bye bye
loser you got because you gas man take
that sh off we are down we are down to
the final round final loser have fun
being
alone who does Jason chenny want to
marry out of the careful who do you
think it was going to be down to me and
Joe who's who are you going to propose
to yeah yeah he either feel I think it's
either he feels that we're Ultra Al
alpha or we're Ultra beta I don't know
the difference but I'm okay cuz I like
to win no I think but
I can we do it like the like how when
you pick the winning fighter like
that but I think no matter what the rest
of you losers over there like I won't
have a relationship with you but I think
no matter what me and Joe whoever gets
picked me and Joe will have a special
bond okay Jason in this last category
who are you most physically attracted to
out of these two all right what the [__]
dude why don't you to ask that earlier
yeah but yeah but that's that's not fair
you're not giving Nick much competition
bro but the thing is like I'm I'm like
an emotional connection type of guy he
doesn't care about looks so huh I you
eliminated I I do care about you're like
the hot girl with no [__] Personality
yeah I'm like the [__] six but a A+
personality you went from numbers to
great
Joe wasn't in the category but if you
pull
back well it's because if I was a c
that's like a 70% but I feel like I'm
more of a d but I don't want to say d
cuz it sounds worse than a six I'm a 7.5
with a Michelin star okay oo you know
about Michelin stars wow you could blend
both of them yeah now well if he's going
to do it I'm going to do it too he
didn't he didn't do it six five I got
nothing
it's just physical you use your eyes
yeah but physical but they're both
[__]
up what do you mean [__] up
wait make him sit make him sit next to
you like surround him all right so
that all right okay ready 6 5
4 2
one hold on hold
on hold on he has to go oh wait I win
wait did I go oh he go he has to
go that's the winner we got to go
outside no he has to go all you guys
make sure you round off the video real
nice all right have a nice hey talk
about your trip your date end the video
end the video all right guys thanks for
watching that's all we're going to do no
Nick you have to be vulnerable nah dude
[__] you man come on man I'll give you a
hug you have to be vulnerable I'll give
you a hug just come in for my tongue
man hey come back in we we kissed
already okay okay thanks for not picking
me you piece of [__] you got me scared I
thought you picked Joe thanks for
watching and uh uh say the thing how do
you feel after I chose you as my it's a
great it's a very great honor um but
dude pour your heart out yeah it's a
great honor we'll see you guys next week
just kidding news Careful by is a brand
just kidding news is the man of smart
people the people of just kidding news
careful Bo they are very smart just
kidding news the number one podcast in
the
world